il aurait essayé de nous troubler
l'esprit diffuser des informations de
démobilisation racontant que monsieur
macro à cause de la pluie ne vient pas
fort de face ce matin
en réalité il vit à fond cet après midi
c'est cet après midi que voir la pluie
donc c'est à n'y rien comprendre
enfin il est important qu'il y a quand
même des combattantes et de combattants
qui sont profondément pénétré de la
conviction que a aidé à cacher ma
technique le café mais des services
d'hôpital
les gones gabon fait mais c'est ma
croûte et permettre que ces 900 équipe a
touché 900 euros et qui dans la
vieillesse ce qui donne la difficulté
c'est qu'on travaille donc ça veut dire
58000 moon qui passent à travers les
cinq à dix nouveaux dia nos cadets porte
sur les services publiques hyundai
l'autre c'est pas seulement la santé
c'est également l'école
et puis à passable tout pour connaître
les récents s'agaçant les nordiques ont
investi dans le var qui mesurent rapport
de sérieux comme ça donc je dis à vous
le sang coule sur mon sac et pourtant
c'est du plaisir organisation quand même
qu'ils jouaient tout ça mais à l'idée
bien sûr c'est de poursuivre la
mobilisation après de se revoir parce
que il nous faut obtenir une négociation
avec l'état il s'agit pas de simplement
de faire semblant d'écouter les
revendications ouvrières il faut
s'asseoir à une table de négociation
discuter et c'est ça qu'on nous le dit
l'état français jordi jours